we're getting closer and closer to the
new iPhone 15 iPhone 15 Pro I actually
can't believe that it is almost here I
mean I say almost we still have a few
months I mean at this point this phone
is definitely finalized I'm sure they're
putting the finishing touches on them
before they will be ready to be revealed
to us so let's just go through and check
out some of the rumors I feel like most
of the things have already been kind of
leaked already so let's see if there's
any updates so this article on 95 Mac I
kind of like because it kind of gives
you the breakdown of Apple's charging
ports of the past so we have the 30 pin
to lightning and it's kind of wild
because I didn't even think about this
Apple only made five models using the
original charging port and that was
launched 16 years ago
16. I know I just can't even handle that
thought and still the public reaction to
when the iPhone 5 switched to the
current lightning Port was not exactly
positive in 2012 says the article and I
don't really remember how I felt I mean
I don't think I was upset about it
necessarily because like that charging
port was so massive that they then went
to something faster and smaller like why
would I don't know I mean at this point
we're like let's go to USBC Are We There
Yet almost usb-a to USBC so Apple began
shipping USBC to lightning cable in the
box with the iPhone 11 Pro now a year
later Apple stopped including the power
adapter to save the planet and replaced
usba to lighten with USBC for the iPhone
12. there are times that I do plug my
phone in if I want to charge faster or
to take footage off of it quicker which
tends to be sometimes faster or a little
bit more reliable than airdrop what's
gonna be cool about airdrop though in
iOS 17 is you'll be able to continue
airdropping photos and videos and con
content not necessarily being next to
the device you'll be able to continue
uploading either on cellular or on Wi-Fi
when you get back to any Wi-Fi service
so that's actually pretty cool and I'm a
huge fan of airdrop so definitely hyped
about that now this is showing a visual
of obviously somebody using magsafe to
charge which I feel like a lot of people
now that's pretty much how you charge
your phone and if you do need to charge
it throughout the day you may be
charging it in your car or just getting
a little juice here there at the office
but for the most part I pretty much do
charge my phone at night on a magnetic
stand all right let's go through the
room around up real quick the iPhone 15
Pro 6.1 and 6.7 inch size is the a17
chip we've got a periscope lens USBC
Port ding ding ding it's here and we'll
have a Qualcomm modem chip I've already
gone through almost all of these specs
so really there's nothing that's like
that new or exciting that has been
leaked I mean this is all super exciting
but I feel like at some point we've seen
this all already so I don't want to keep
rehashing everything so here we have the
USBC here's a little side shot here
they're showing you the dynamic Island
and the hole punch for the camera the
thinner bezel design will be noticeable
as seen in the photo below comparing the
iPhone 14 pro and the iPhone 15 Pro
mock-up wow actually take a look at that
seems like a significant difference I
mean there's definitely still a bezel
but in comparison to the previous
version it definitely looks much thinner
the volume buttons won't have notable
changes but they are expected to swap
the mute switch with a button instead
interesting breaking news so I had
already filmed my iOS 15 rumors video
and then this news just broke about the
fourth beta of iOS 17 came out and
leaked that there is going to be an
action button so according to some code
Snippets the new button replaces the
mute switch will have plenty of options
that can be assigned to a click So based
on their findings the iPhone 15 Pro
button will have nine assignment options
accessibility shortcuts silent mode
camera flashlight Focus Mac magnifier
translate and voice memos so you'll be
able to assign this to do all sorts of
actions so I can't wait to check this
out if it is actually a thing we don't
really know it's just a rumor so saying
the iPhone 15 Pro Max could be slightly
thicker than the iPhone 14 pro Max with
small reductions in the height and width
of course we can't make it the same size
because we definitely need to make sure
that the previous cases that you bought
for your 14 will not fit the 15. very
important we're gonna have a titanium
chassis obviously titanium is already
being used in the Apple watch which is
beautiful and light and I'm actually not
wearing my Apple watch Ultra today I
thought I'd switch it up get a little
wild with the the gold so here's some
color options it could be available in a
dark blue color which is yeah that's
definitely not far off from the iPhone
12 Pro but a more gray for a Deeper
Shade they've heard rumors of red which
I'm sure it'll look better in person I'm
just not a real big fan of the color red
and I'm sure we will have the gray the
gold and silver is that what I said Greg
old yeah gray gold silver space gray who
knows what they call it maybe they'll
call it something new here's some
mock-ups of the 15 here's some case
options there's also been rumors about
the iPhone 15 Ultra which I still don't
feel like that's gonna happen this year
I don't know it kind of would sort of
make sense that they would kind of
piggybacking off of the Apple watch
Ultra so here's a render of what the
Periscope camera could look like so this
should allow for 5x or 6X optical zoom
and in comparison to the iPhone 14 pro
Max that offers 3x so we'll basically be
getting possibly double the zoom some
other camera improvements the iPhone 15
Pro Models are expected to include
improved rear camera and a lidar scanner
from Sony I feel like Apple's going to
be really leaning more into lidar and AR
obviously with the introduction of
Vision Pro so it's going to be
interesting to see how they start
catering towards creators or even just
regular consumers who aren't looking to
be a content creator but you're still
taking videos and photos how they're
going to be enhancing these devices to
make all of the content look great for
Vision Pro battery suggests the iPhone
15 models will use stacked Battery
Technology okay hopefully that'll give
us some better battery life I do feel
like right now my battery in my phone
this is about the time where it starts
draining so now the iPhone 15 not pro
that's the phone that is supposedly
going to have the pink version I just
wish so much that they would bring a
pink to the pro but it's okay I end up
putting a case on it anyways I'm never
gonna see what color I actually forgot
what color I had I have silver in case
you forgot as well so here's the whole
lineup we've got the 6.1 inch iPhone 15
the 6.1 inch iPhone 15 Pro the 6.7 inch
iPhone 15 Max and the 6.7 inch iPhone 15
Pro Max
there's so much there's so much now the
Pro Models will have a higher end
feature and will be more expensive while
the standard iPhone 15 models will be
the less expensive as usual and of
course you've seen this image before
this pink is a possibility and the blue
is also beautiful those are really
really great colors here's another
little render of the iPhone 15s frosted
glass oh interesting the iPhone 15
models could feature a frosted glass
back which have been previously a design
detail that apple is limited to the Pro
Models that could be interesting I don't
know if they'll do that because I feel
like they need to have something that is
that differential feature between the
pro and like just the regular phones so
here's some part leaks and some renders
literally looks like it could be
anything
I mean I think they're just showing this
because you can see kind of like where
the dynamic island is but not the best
photo iPhone 15 on the left 15 plus on
the right it's just
hard because like these phones are
already so great so like how much more
can you do to them to make them look
different I mean we're doing kind of
incremental upgrades at this point but
yeah so that so far is what we're
looking at for the iPhone 15 and the 15
Pros so I'd love to hear from you guys
though is there anything that you're
looking forward to in the next iPhone I
would love to read all of your comments
below so leave those and with that I
will see you guys in my next video don't
forget to like comment and subscribe hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos and of course we've got more
videos here on the end screen so I'll
see you in the next one peace